[Music]
so bart go ahead and tell us how much
you hate california gas prices they're
not fun it's actually pretty bad in
vegas too though like when i drove back
the other week you don't see pretty bad
stuff about vegas
i got it for dollars and 27 cents that's
a weird flex brand
depends on where you go five dollars and
twenty because there are tourist trap
places where i was like i was pumping
like what the terrible yeah yeah i'm
like this is la prices and i'm like oh
because they know everyone's gonna stop
here but if you go in the actual suburbs
it's lower five dollars and twenty seven
cents you know how much you know much
gas was in el salvador because they used
the us dollar it was like 420 to like
five bucks oh my god in texas it's like
four dollars oh yeah but the economy is
very different in also well somewhere in
california
they were selling premium gas for 69
cents well i heard about that on
accident why how because they uh they
moved the decimal point or something the
wrong direction california gas station
manager who now lost his job over this
yeah he mistakenly set the gas price to
69 cents when it should have been 6.99
and when did he realize hours later
after
over 20 thousand dollars of premium gas
had been sold at that point how
how did he not notice so that's like
five trucks that just filled up you know
how do you set the price too is it like
digital or something when i first saw
the headliners i cracked up because i
thought he just was playing the joke and
put it to 69 cents
[ __ ] funny supposed to be like 6.90
or something 6.99 but it turned into 69
cents
uh this was at a shell station in rancho
cordova california and then customers
for whatever reason once people started
seeing it or like hearing about it
people were texting their friends hell
yeah man the station got super pumped
within a couple of hours i'd go there
with empty barrels yeah for real so this
whole time this fool didn't even know
and he's like man it's a busy day
it's so busy
and then they're like man people are
only getting like three dollars of gas i
don't know why can you change the the
the like price mid
like midday or do you have to keep the
price for the whole day no no you could
change you could well the digital ones
there's guys out there they're making
like videos of they had like master
remotes and they would change the
digital like
yeah
it was like [ __ ] it up but then
this seems like one of those things
where it's in the system because you
know you can pay at the [ __ ] pump
right yeah and then it's like linked to
the whole system yeah right so like for
example my car takes 20 gallons at 69
cents it would cost me 13
[ __ ] dream dude what a [ __ ] dream
at premium this is the premium gas price
too i remember in high school
uh me and my homies were going to
morongo all the time and it was only 89
cents what at mcdonald's but only like
every yeah everyone would chip in like
five bucks and we felt like we can go
anywhere i remember that [ __ ] under a
dollar was insane yeah it was so easy to
do road trips because i remember like as
soon as you get your license one of the
things you wanted to do is just [ __ ]
drive all the damn time right but you
didn't have gas money but it was like
you just [ __ ] don't eat lunch that
day and everyone pitches in and you can
[ __ ] go to santa monica you could go
everywhere remember you could just kind
of scrounge for change in your car and
then you can get it you can get some
good old guess with that yeah
everyone can [ __ ] put some money
together you get you fill up like a
quarter tank and then you can get buy
some 7-eleven snacks yup some cigarettes
some slurpee or 39-cent cheeseburgers at
the same
time you know what's funny though like
the the older folks were looking at our
generation like man man i was able to
get this [ __ ] for like two cents
it's like
i used to drink gasoline i remember
there was outrage when gas was like
three dollars a gallon everybody was
like pissed three dollars this is
ridiculous some places it's seven or
eight bucks now yeah but then they just
skipped all the way to seven dude
seven third on the way over here i saw a
gas price for 7 30. do you guys remember
during kovid like they just dumped a
[ __ ] ton of gas because they had like
the logistics was all backed up and
they're like was gonna cost more to
store it and then gas prices went like
it dipped so hard
little did people know you're gonna have
a hard pump
didn't trump didn't trump know
did trump know yeah didn't he like buy a
shitload of reserves and like put it
away oh really for like yeah when the
price went down he like bought a
shitload of gasoline or oil put them in
like a storage center or something and
then were they cool because because they
have the
the the national like petroleum reserves
too he like he like capitalized on that
dip he got a tip from pelosi yeah and he
left office and then came in and then
biden opened the reserve and then trump
was like what the [ __ ] if i didn't set
it on fire
sorry as you fell down the stairs with
the airport air force one something like
that i thought it was interesting well
trump has a lot of casinos that probably
are vacant because a lot of people that
hate him now so he could just store the
barrels there
you think it's a slot machine it's a
[ __ ] oil barrel yeah
what do you think the highest price of
gas we're gonna see in california is
gonna be oh ten dollars 15. you mean by
the end of this year they're gonna have
to redesign the [ __ ] signs because
you can't even go that way it needs to
fit four digits right that was like well
good thing it's only gonna cap out at
9.99 because they don't have that extra
digit now like joke's on you [ __ ]
there's not one uh place in norcal i
think on the way to monterey bay that's
notorious for high gas prices yeah it's
on the um the pch my buddy he was
driving to big sur
he goes i had to buy gas up there and
how much was gas he goes ten dollars a
gallon oh and i was like did you jump
off the [ __ ] bridge
the ones in big sur like the drive to
big sur sometimes like i get was so
expensive like [ __ ] trucking trucking
this [ __ ] up here to get it at this
weird ass [ __ ] station i get why this
is like expensive as [ __ ] it's it's
you're in the middle of [ __ ] like you
should be taking the five if you're on
big sur you're there for the road trip
yeah you're there today and if you fill
up before it's not that bad it's for
people that didn't plan do he had to
fill up again that would cost me 200
bucks to fill up
fire filled up over there dude he's
bragging how big his [ __ ] gas tank is
this guy
with a dick
it cost me 400
you should just like fill up off of his
tank when he's parked out yeah siphon
gas out of his [ __ ] thanks bart
how many gallons is your car like 22 25
yeah we should cycle
you're the one who's got to take the the
first one though you know what i mean
yeah we're all communists here oh yeah
yeah we're almost surprised i got the
pump thing where you just pump like that
and it goes off the other half you have
to suck it no you have to take a sip
that's how they do in the movies you
can't just pump it that's cool have you
ever like siphoned something no
aquarium yeah but and i try not to let
the water touch my mouth
for an aquarium you know i changed
aquarium water oh yeah you got a siphon
so you siphon like half of the yucky
water and you put fresh water in yeah at
these i'll change the water fish are all
dead
cut to his tank at home some you don't
yeah
like some you eat 80
like the betta fish in your bowl you see
uh biden was trying to like reduce taxes
on um
the tax relief day for the no for gas
like i'll take away 18 cents worth of
tax yeah per gallon i'm like what the
shut my dick dude
but he's still maintaining that it's all
cause of putin right
every video i see he's like saying it
more and more and more but every graph i
see it's like inflation happened here
under like biden and then putin was like
here so it actually like plateaued over
here it's all inflation yeah but it's
like and taxes yeah but it all happened
already before
putin came in i saw a funny comment that
was like um actually it was more than a
comment i think it's a whole article
saying like
like people shouldn't expect the
president to be able to do anything
about gas prices
i was like we shouldn't then i saw the
meme that goes
don't worry guys i'm gonna help control
the gas prices but then the meme is i
thought you just said you can't control
the gas prices and now you're saying you
can control the get so which one is it
all right he's too busy [ __ ] riding
bikes everywhere dude why is why is joe
biden on a bike
he has a bad pr team dude what was the
point of him being on that bike i don't
know what was the event for
they need to keep him or his feet are on
the ground or something just keep him
make him look good yeah i'm just worried
for him now because it feels like a
fragile grandpa that shouldn't be doing
things
like it feels like hey grandpa don't get
up down that ladder just don't [ __ ]
oh you [ __ ] did it look i i just told
joe biden to suck my dick but i do feel
bad that he fell off that bike
i was like dude this is making me feel
comfortable at his age yeah bro
i was like this dude is so fragile right
now it was funny how slow of a follow us
takes his pants off and he has so much
[ __ ] bruising on his leg right
no i don't know
six months yeah dude apparently the
screenshot of him uh falling from that
bike has been debunked
wait what i mean there's a video of him
falling no i think wait the screenshot
of his like leg or something like that
oh no i made that up but i didn't i
didn't know that he got bruised
yeah i didn't find joel
but you know old people when they get
hit you know they fall like they bruise
really easily i would imagine he'd be
the same what if they're just like they
debunked the whole video they're like he
actually falls onto another bike
he didn't let him finish the video he's
switching bikes man and you're just
riding the floor it's a relay race
you ever relay race
[ __ ] idiots wait so that's not real
that he fell off a bike right here no
there was like a there's like a fake
photo going around
oh he fell he fell but there's like a
photo photo paired with the real video
yeah that's a really really good setup
what's all the ingredients what's the
fake photo though i want to know is it
is it this
i don't know what's wrong with that
picture there's nothing wrong with that
picture
worth faking
dude now we're not even letting them in
show them people are going to
unsubscribe
they've already clicked out by now
i would have show them guys wait so
there's nothing wrong with this photo
someone needs to edit joe biden fallen
from the bike and then doing the splits
and like he meant to do it like james
brown yeah james probably [ __ ] james
brown like and he picks himself up and
he goes gotcha and he gets up and goes
this is
[Music]
you